Mind your Decisions, I'm Presh Talwalkar.
8 - 4 = 61.(lol wut?)
The challenge is to move only 2 sticks to make a correct equation.(oh ok)
I thank Dvir, who created this problem and sent it to me.
I admit, this puzzle fooled me!
You're only allowed to move 2 sticks to make a correct equation.
You may also have to change your perspective to solve this one.
Pause the video if you'd like to give this problem a try,
and when you're ready,
keep watching to learn how to solve this problem.
So here's the answer:
First, we'll make the 4 into a 11 by moving this stick.
Then, we'll make this = sign into a - sign,
and vice versa by moving this one stick.(also liveoverflow is best channel)
And this is the correct answer.
Now, you might say, "8 = 11 - 61 is NOT the correct equation!"
BUT,  to get the correct equation,
you have to change your perspective.
Look at this equation upside down.
To illustrate this,
I'm going to rotate the entire diagram
so you can see what it would look like upside down.
You then get the equation
19 - 11 = 8,
and that's the correct answer!
So the next time you're stuck on a problem,
take a step back,
and consider changing your perspective.
It might make all the difference!
Thanks for making Mind your Decisions one of the best channels on Youtube.
As always,  thanks for watching,
and thanks for your support.
i stayed up at 1:15 in the morning to do this so you better not fucking disrespect the people who make CC on youtube videos